[Music]
so your dad is picking us up no problem
okay well don't do anything I wouldn't
do I said you have to shine a light on
my raging hormones a lot of people know
you from Summerlin is there any chance
of a reunion of getting the squad back
together I don't know what this story
would be at this point and I guess
anything's possible anything and I feel
like you guys have all gone in different
directions but you could just bring it
back in we can kind of get that vibe
going once more it would be fun I know
that there's a little the show I went to
the Super Bowl I actually ran into Jesse
McCartney at the Super Bowl I hadn't
seen him in a while it was good to see
him he looks great what do you guys talk
about oh we've just reminisce tale'
ittle bit about the show and just you
know chatting I'm not actively pursuing
anything but sure I loved all those guys
I love that show I thought it was really
great fun joy nice cool really really
cool I could've done without that second
really oh it's okay he was just such a
young kid with a gap between his teeth
we start on our show it was so funny
before he was the heartthrob Nicky was
14 years old and he was always cute you
know but he really yeah he really
morphed into quite the Hong Kong